este edificio que está a mis espaldas
que está prácticamente destruido es un
colegio aquí estudiaban mil alumnos
hasta el comienzo de la invasión el 24
de febrero está localizado en la parte
sureste de la ciudad de mykolaiv este
gran puerto sobre el mar negro una
ciudad estratégica en la defensa de la
ciudad de odessa pero también para la
contraofensiva de la región de gerzón y
la capital gerson que en este momento
libran las tropas ucranianas este
colegio fue atacado días atrás pero no
es la única institución educativa que ha
sido atacada en esta ciudad
especialmente en este sector de la
ciudad a menos de tres kilómetros de
aquí otro colegio fue atacado también
quedó totalmente
destruido los testigos y habitantes del
sector dicen que no habían militares
adentro que solamente estaba el
vigilante sin embargo lo que sucede con
mykolaiv es justo una ciudad que es
constantemente atacada en el día en la
noche
permanentemente y esto sea en científica
intensificado desde que comenzó esa
ofensiva contra la región de gerzón que
en la que tienen grandes esperanzas las
tropas y el gobierno ucraniano